remember in the first footnote how I
said there are 23 Catholic churches
within the Catholic Church all with
different traditions this is one of the
times that matters only the Latin Church
the largest of the 23 requires priests
to be celibate the other 22 Catholic
churches known as the eastern churches
allow married men to become priests but
not to advance any more but even this is
a bit of an oversimplification because
priests in the Latin church can be
married under certain circumstances most
notably former Anglican priests who were
married at the time of their conversion
to Catholicism are not required to
relinquish their wives but as with the
Eastern Churches their marriage prevents
them from rising any higher